rebels now confident that a majority of
the party have turned against the prime
minister with what we've seen over the
past few days with the lack of integrity
and many mps going back to their
constituents and having to look them in
the eye and have that integrity i think
that's what's changed and that's why
people are moving today
victory in a confidence vote would
usually buy a year before the next
challenge the strength of feeling in the
party means those rule changes could
change very soon
he's a political leader like no other in
our history any other leader would have
gone way before now but boris keeps
hanging on but there comes a point where
that's simply not sustainable and i
think we're beyond that point now he
will go the question is when and in what
manner this has to be dealt with has to
be dealt with now either by senior
ministerial colleagues or by the 1922
committee
extraordinarily boris johnson continues
in power but the rebels are clear if he
clings on the battle just moves to next
week where on monday they think they've
got the votes to change the rules so
that on tuesday there can be another
vote of no confidence in this prime
minister but everybody is clear on one
other thing this needs to be resolved by
the summer holidays which are in less
than three weeks time
mps thinking changing pm now is better
than the alternative he has damaged the
conservative brand by the way he's
behaved and i'm just very saddened about
that truly suffering because i don't
want to see that happen to the party but
i think if we get um probably the deputy
prime minister run the country until we
get a new leader and then i think we can
put it behind us and move forward
because the country needs running
there's lots of issues to deal with
will boris johnson become the third
prime minister ousted in six years he
insists that it's the will of the people
for him to continue much of his cabinet
and party disagree
it may take till next week to resolve
either way
sam coates sky news westminster